i think it was because of you [ __ ] with
me when people chop and they do the
di
i feel like um
sometimes it's amazing
sometimes there's guys like ritz from
gwinnett county who could rap really
fast and say incredible things yeah um
tech9 is really good at that yeah but
then sometimes it's like
unbearable it's it's like really
unbearable you know what i actually i'm
just like this
i hate i hate it though like this is who
i am i can't shake it listen to that
[ __ ] though i wouldn't would you would
you listen to your own album yes okay
because my [ __ ] is fire yes it's some
[ __ ] [ __ ]
can't comment on that
no idea what you're talking about
but
and i'll respect it and all but i
it's kind of crazy i don't be like
really delving into it if i know this is
your niche i don't think it's my niche i
think i could just do it i just do it
like you know what i'm saying
effortlessly effortless i'm not trying
to rap like this my name is
jittery for a reason cause i'm just like
my brain like but
i don't really
aim for that style of music right you or
i wouldn't even say rap is the first
thing i would press play on in my car
yeah i feel like eminem for being like
one of the greatest rappers of all time
i don't like when he raps like that
it's not for me but shout out to him
curtin call two out now
oh god did you listen to eminem growing
up
i i i used to love stan still listen to
he's a great first three hours i saw
like first three albums are great yeah
yeah all of the craziness yes that's the
g unit [ __ ] that whole era but i was i
wasn't like
super am i like
wait it was eminem like super prominent
two thousand [ __ ] two until yeah i
mean no no
technically
like 99. i'm saying 98.99 the total
poison at this time i'm really like at
this age i'm really like catching up on
i'm in a new orleans sound i'm really
400 degrees all of that